the new cd is self-titled and i wanted
to self-title this album because i feel
that when my fans hear it they'll get a
sense of who i am matrix
that's all i can say
because it's so top secret
it was jed's idea actually to do the
whole kind of dance choreography fight
scene and took three days to shoot and i
did all my own stunts so one of my
favorite scenes definitely i've always
wanted to work with x so to finally get
together and do this duet was great
[Music]
uh this is the most fun because this is
my peer group you know this is young
america so it really feels good to see
people that are close to your age that
support you but even though you're a
huge star is there somebody here you'd
like to meet i want to meet venus and
serena williams big fan big fan of
theirs
but what do you mean what are you going
to say i'm going to say you guys are
absolutely amazing you're awesome and i
totally admire you i'd like for them to
teach me tennis
i want to learn how to fly so maybe we
can like hook up and they can show me a
few things a new cd self-titled and i
wanted to self-title this album because
i feel that when my fans hear it they'll
get a sense of who i am
[Music]
it's a fun album it's got something for
everybody it's uh
got a little bit of latin a little bit
of jazz a little bit of hip-hop a little
bit of everything and i think it's my
best work today so i'm very happy about
it
[Music]
am i supposed to supposed
are you supposed to
yeah the snakes
love it and i was a little nervous at
first but then once i started to handle
them i realized that
they're really beautiful creatures
they're actually pretty gentle and
they're very sexy and i liked that and i
felt that they could represent me well
for the album you know they're a bit
mysterious they're a bit dangerous the
ones that i'm handling are very real we
had 10 pythons and we had 40 smaller
snakes that are crawling on the ground
in some of the scenes
and they're real the songs speak about
relationships all kinds of relationships
bad ones good ones there's even a song
that speaks about an abusive
relationship so touching a lot of
different subjects the world has changed
since you reigned then we shall change
it back
humans are animals
creatures queen of the damned it's the
third brick in the unrice vampire
chronicles tells the story of the queen
who's
um awakened by lestat's rock music and
comes back to take over the world and
the other ancient vampires of her time
feel that she must be stumped you think
you can change my will
had enough of this discussion
i had a lot of fun doing that film i was
very excited to be a part of a vampire
film because i have been a lover of
vampires since i was very very young
and
not only was it just a vampire film it
was anne rice who is i mean she's anne
rice kash is very
regal
very grand
um so yeah a lot of great costumes she's
sexy but she's evil
very evil
upgrades matrix
that's all i can say
because it's so top secret i don't know
much about the matrix and um we have to
keep it that way it's going to be a
while before that's released and it's
like his lips are sealed with that one
were you a fan of the first one a big
fan very very big fan i flew from
australia to la to go out for it i was
like i have to be a part of it it's the
star wars of our time i would love to be
a part of it anyway the album comes out
june 19th that's the next big thing and
then i'm going to shoot the matrix
sequels and then i have queen of the
damn the
second book in the ann rice vampire
chronicles will be out next year so a
lot of things to look forward to
you